it seems we've all had trouble getting
our ps5 pre-orders in
but good news for ps plus subscribers
there's another pair of free games
coming soon
here's what you can get your hands on in
october
since it's spooky season ps4's first
free game is vampire
this rpg puts you behind the cape of you
guessed it
a vampire as you explore london's four
districts
you'll make dialogue choices as you
speak to potential victims for feeding
and you'll use your supernatural vampire
powers in combat too
the second ps plus game isn't scary at
all unless you don't like driving
it's need for speed payback set in the
vegas inspired fortune valley
this need for speed game lets you swap
between three different drivers
each with their own special skills it's
also loaded with fast and the furious
inspired action scenes
and those are your free playstation plus
games for october they'll be available
from october 6
through november 2nd remember that you
can always check out gameplay clips and
reviews for these titles on gamespot
and stay tuned as we report on the new
ps plus lineup every month
[Music]
you